Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thank you everyone
that asked questions on my Listen video and
the Bonus video.
I’ll say 90% of everything was Barn-related,
which sounds about right.
Also, you guys have some really good theories
about the barn as well as missy, danny pink
and some of the big twists in series 8.
So keep it up.
Good tv is always worth talking about.
I’ll announce the winner of the giveaway
at the end of the video.
The next round will start when I post my episode
5 review, so be sure to subscribe if you’re
new and you want to participate in that.
Big reminder, careful for spoilers from Episode
4 if you haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Matthew Tam.
If Gallifrey was locked in the pocket universe
how did the TARDIS get there?
There are two ways you can think about this.
The first is that it wasn’t gallifrey and
the other is that Moffat never intends to
explicitly say yes or no this is or is not
Gallifrey.
The reason I said it was Gallifrey in my review
video was because I read a spoiler from TV
Guide magazine that said Series 8 would include
a stop-over on gallifrey, but not a proper
Doctor visit.
Obviously they were talking about this episode.
TV Guide is generally known for being really
good with it’s facts so I didn’t doubt
them.
Some of you have pointed out that the way
they cut the scene with the john hurt footage
causes some logic issues because Gallifrey
doesn’t have a blue sky.
So if TV Guide was wrong and it’s not Gallifrey,
it’s probably Karn, just because I think
the barn is meant to be the Doctor’s childhood
home as well as the barn from the 50th just
as a nice visual trilogy.
He goes to Karn to become the war doctor,
goes back to end the universe and then recently,
we found that was also where he grew up before
going to the academy.
We’ll call that the “Not Gallifrey”
explanation.
I think in Real Life, Moffat, when pressed
about this at conventions, will just use the
same type of logic he used to get them to
gallifrey in the 50th.
The Moment had timey wimey powers that were
able to negate the Time Lock.
This episode wasn’t written till after the
50th Anniversary episode was written.
So when Moffat wrote the John Hurt Barn scene,
he didn’t know that he’d take them back
there in series 8.
So I think a lot of the continuity issues
are just based on that.
I still kind of think it’s Gallifrey and
Moffat tried to work within his own pre-established
canon and it got a little messy.
Whatever the explanation really is, if it’s
something else.
I don’t think it’s going to help the Doctor
bring Gallifrey back.
I think Gallifrey won’t come back anytime
soon.
I think Missy and the finale will have something
to do with it.
Not bringing it back, but finding it.
Big takeaway, if you get really confused with
Moffat stories fitting into Canon, just think
like Moffat.
And try to keep it simple.
Question 2 - Septogram 7.
Do you think The Doctor will ever show Clara
the Toy Soldier or realize she was the one
who gave it to him?
The Doctor stores all kinds of things from
each of his lives in the TARDIS, so it’s
possible the toy soldier is somewhere hidden
away and forgotten.
But I think the soldier will be more important
as a metaphor for the finale.
As it relates to Danny Pink and Missy.
I don’t think the actual toy soldier itself
will be as important.
I do like the idea that The First Doctor kept
it with him when he went to the academy and
then later when he stole the TARDIS.
Question 3 - Dbz Axel.
Any thoughts on Courtney the girl from Coal
Hill School?
She’s been mentioned or appeared in most
of the episodes so far?
I think there are two possible explanations.
One is that they’re just trying to make
Coal Hill feel like more of a real place that
exists even when the Doctor and Clara aren’t
around.
So they just create characters that are associated
with it.
And the other explanation is that yes she
is extra special and will have something to
do with a future episode.
The synopsis for The Caretaker episode implies
that The Doctor will go to Coal Hill himself.
That episode was written by Gareth Edwards,
who wrote The Lodger and Closing Time, two
episodes where the Doctor went and spent time
away from his companions.
So the doctor could wind up spending a lot
of time with this courtney person in the episode.
Question 4 - Dayvis.
Is Danny Pink ever going to go on a proper
adventure with the Doctor or will he always
be stuck in present day?
Samuel Anderson clarified his status a little
by saying he’s a companion to the companion.
But I believe I read somewhere that he will
actually go on board the TARDIS at some point.
I don’t know if that’s in the next couple
of weeks or if it’s only near the finale.
But I don’t think he’ll have an adventure
without Clara also being there.
At least based on what Anderson is implying.
There’s actually a funny story he told about
what he was doing when he found out he got
the show.
He said his agent called and told he he’d
booked it.
Then because he was in a room with a bunch
of his friends he told them and they all cheered.
But then his agent called back and said, don’t
tell anyone…
And he was like, “I just told a room full
of people…”
Question 5 - Programmer X.
Was there something under the bed?
What was under the covers and what’s under
your bed?
Yes there was definitely something under the
bed.
You can interpret it as you want, but I think
they were meant to be a new monster that we’d
just never see full on.
As in, we’d never see what’s under the
bedsheet.
As a story telling device, it’s great.
Because Moffat doesn’t have to spend money
on special effects and makeup.
Capaldi’s doctor has been backtracking a
lot on some of his conclusions.
So it’s totally possible the hands under
the bed belong to other people, not monsters.
I think it’s another one of those Moffat
things, where he has the premise in his head
about the shared nightmare and he’s like,
what if we can never know what they look like.
And he just wants everyone to argue about
whether or not they a real deal new monster
or if there’s a more logical explanation.
Question 6 - Dark Neko Studio.
Why hasn’t the doctor been trying to find
gallifrey or repair his mistakes of the past?
That’s what I think the Blackboards are
all about.
All the quantum physics equations.
He said when he wrote Listen, he wanted to
show what the Doctor does, when he’s all
by himself with nothing to do.
So what I think is happening is, The Doctor
is taking his time in finding Gallifrey, it’s
not going anywhere and the Time Lords are
safe, as far as we know.
And I think this story was just a pause in
the fixing mistakes of the past.
It’s hard to tell how urgent he was when
he said it was time to start correcting things.
He wasn’t shouting it at Clara, so it seems
like he’s not in a rush.
Question 7 - Aliya Aliyaa.
What if the boy under the blanket wasn’t
the Doctor but the Master?
That’s a really interesting thought!
It would be a big WTF twist.
But the reason I think it was the Doctor is
because of the way the Doctor explained all
the Danny Pink run-ins.
Clara was slaved to the TARDIS so it was traveling
to people connected to her timestream.
So for it to take her to The Master, she would
at some time have had to interact with him
in a substantial way.
There was gallifreyan clara, but I think that’s
reaching a bit far.
There was someone in the comments that suggested
the Doctor was crying because it was around
the time he and the Master were exposed to
the Untempered Schism.
The moment when the Doctor started to hear
the drum beats.
That’s totally possible too.
I don’t think that’s what Moffat was thinking
when he wrote the doctor crying in his sleep
though.
Question 8 - The Elijah Talk.
Can we mention it’s implied Clara and Danny
settle down?
It’s definitely implied, but when Orson
Pink said Time Travel runs in the family he
could also have just been referencing Danny
Pink’s relationship with The Doctor and
Clara.
Not that they ended up getting married and
having children.
I don’t want to make too many Danny Clara
theories before seeing the finale.
Because supposedly there are crazy things
happening that would negate a lot of those
theories.
Companions totally get to settle down, but
I think it’s tradition for them to meet
some untimely end.
Like with Amy, Rory and the weeping Angels.
They got to get married and have a child,
but they still became prisoners of the angels.
Question 9 - Walking Who.
How do you feel about the Doctor not knowing
where they were during the barn scene?
Do you think he should know?
Assuming he doesn’t know about it, I think
it’s okay.
The scene where clara told him to never go
back was more about him trusting her.
And the idea of broken trust is a big deal
over the course of series 8.
The doctor trusting people and them breaking
that trust.
People trusting the doctor and him breaking
I think it will all play into whatever Missy
is doing.
Question 10 - Rob Rubb.
With both the episode and Doctor Who Extra
making deliberate references to the Doctor’s
past, will we see a moffat loop that takes
the story back to another major first doctor
moment like stealing the TARDIS?
I like that you call it a Moffat Loop, like
it’s a mobius strip or something.
I do think that Missy will have something
to do with his ancient past, like back to
the first doctor.
But I don’t think it will be related to
him stealing the TARDIS.
I think it will be a big moment from the past
we haven’t ever seen before.
Although there is a big scene in the finale
that’s a direct homage to a second doctor
scene.
They did that scene in the series 7 finale
with gallifreyan clara telling him which TARDIS
to steal.
But I don’t think Moffat’s carrying that
forward.
I’m starting to think Missy is someone totally
new, but new in that she’s never been done
before, but she’s someone from the Doctor’s
past.
I’m not expecting to see other versions
of the doctor on screen with Capaldi.
Thanks so much for submitting questions, I
don’t think we’ll ever be completely satisfied
with the Barn theories but that’s just one
more big question to ask Moffat himself if
you ever get the chance.
Since there was a big teaser for old criminals
from Doctor Who history in the Episode 5 teaser,
my next bonus video will be about my favorite
Doctor Who Criminals.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And congratulations to DogeFresh for winning
this week’s giveaway.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
So be sure to check your inbox.
Next round starts when I post my Episode 5
review.
Right now click here for my Episode 4 review
and click here for my top 5 scary episodes.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!